the Super Bowl continues and we get a
look at Iron Man 3 now when I watched
his trailer I was like why does that
seem like it's the last 15 epic seconds
of a trailer where they show the big
moment and nothing else oh that's
because that's exactly what it is
because you have to go on their facebook
website so you can watch the rest of the
trailer that's how it works these days I
understand that nevertheless I gotta
look at Iron Man 3 through the Super
Bowl and through the facebook website
iron man 3 is looking pretty good and
I'll tell you why not a fan of iron man
2 not a big fan of that movie it was
clearly rushed out of the door very fast
the studios wanted it out there Jon
Favreau wasn't able to put his full
stamp on and I could tell everyone just
felt not entirely right about that movie
Iron Man 3 is getting a little bit of a
revamping its directed and written by
shane black wow the kiss kiss bang bang
filmmaker also with Robert Downey jr.
great film Shane Black also is that dude
from predator with the glasses yeah just
to throw that bit of news on you we get
a kind of funny look at Robert Downey
jr. and beginning this trailer and I'm
not entirely sure if that will be in the
movie or if that was filmed entirely for
this super bowl trailer pretty sure it
was for the trailer which is kind of
interesting they would do that but
nevertheless this movie is looking
pretty frickin sweet the most part the
first half the trailers a lot of the
same stuff we've seen before but you
know what I'm okay with that because I'm
assuming that towards the release date
they're going to start releasing a whole
bunch of trailers that give away too
much and it's going to take me off and
I'm just not going to watch them after
this more than likely because I like the
fact i don't know that much about it i'm
assuming that towards the release date
they're going to start releasing a whole
bunch of trailers that give away too
much and it's going to take me off and
I'm just not going to watch them after
this more than likely because i like the
fact i don't know that much about it the
last shot with iron man flying out of
the plane and rescuing all the people
you can tell they're going to create
like a circle of people all holding
hands since you can only carry four
looks pretty awesome iron man 3 is
definitely one of my most anticipated
movies for the rest of this year I am
excited to see one of my favorite
superheroes hopefully get a little bit
of a wash and clean and buff job that's
what I'm hoping to pore through Shane
Black looking forward to the movie what
did you guys think of the trailer let me
know below I also reviewed the fast and
the furious 6 trailer and start
r 2 is coming up as well thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always would be
like this and you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you